de muchas maneras esta cena resume mis
primeros dos años en el cargo hablaré
durante 10 minutos No responderé
preguntas y me iré alegremente
fue una noche para recordar en la casa
blanca la cena anual de corresponsales
reunió a celebridades y magnates de los
medios para una velada de bromas
políticas y recordatorios de las
amenazas a la libertad de prensa por
primera vez desde 2016 el presidente
biden y la primera dama junto con la
vicepresidenta camala Harris y el
segundo caballero doehave presidieron el
evento la cena había quedado en un
segundo plano durante la pandemia y fue
criticada anteriormente por el
expresidente Donald Trump mientras
estaba en el cargo entre bromas sobre su
edad y la filtración de documentos
clasificados vayan a bordó de manera más
seria el tema de la libertad de prensa
como el pedido de liberación de Evan
Girls detenido en Rusia y Austin tize
desaparecido en Siria
tan solo dos de los cientos de
periodistas encarcelados en el
extranjero sus familias asistieron a la
cena biden también hizo un guiño al
millonario acuerdo entre Fox news y la
empresa de conteo de votos dominion
systems luego de que un tribunal
señalara que la cadena de televisión
difundió falsas acusaciones de fraude
electoral es fantástico que las cadenas
de noticias por cable estén aquí esta
noche como
propiedad de nbc Universal y Fox news
propiedad de dominion System entre otras
invitados se encontraban la estrella del
baloncesto Britney Warner quien recibió
una mención especial después de haber
estado detenida casi 10 meses en Rusia
el año pasado
[Aplausos]